Parecía un sueño pero lo consiguió a sus
77 años Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
juramentó por tercera vez como
presidente de Brasil acompañado por una
mujer un líder indígena un niño negro un
trabajador y una persona con
discapacidad Recibió la banda
presidencial Con un fuerte simbolismo
del Brasil que quiere gobernar Unido y
en contra de la desigualdad
[Aplausos]
en la puerta de los comedores en busca
de algo para aliviar el hambre
y al mismo tiempo filas de espera para
la compra de automóviles importados y
yates particulares
tamaño tremendo Abismo Social es un
obstáculo para la construcción de una
sociedad verdaderamente justa y
democrática
entre coros de sus seguidores y muchas
lágrimas el mensaje más presente durante
sus dos discursos fue la llamada a un
país Unido en una Clara alusión a los
cerca de 58 millones de votantes de Jair
bolsonaro
voy a gobernar para 215 millones de
brasileños y brasileñas y no solo para
aquellos que votaron por mí Voy a
gobernar para todos y para todas viendo
hacia nuestro futuro en común
sin olvidar los retos a los que se
enfrenta Lula prometió reconstruir el
país sumido en una crisis económica y
una fuerte desigualdad social la razón
por la que aseguró ha vuelto al plan
alto poder asegurarse de que todos los
brasileños tienen tres comidas del día
como debería garantizar a cualquier
régimen democrático
con la fuerza del pueblo y la bendición
de Dios reconstruiremos este país viva
la democracia viva el pueblo brasileño
rodeado de líderes y representantes
políticos de otros países el petista
aprovechó para lanzar un último mensaje
piensa volver a situar a Brasil una de
las economías en desarrollo más potentes
del mundo en el mapa de nuevo una de las
muchas tareas pendientes para estos
cuatro años